now for more legal analysis we bring in
Fox News contributor Jonathan Turley
Jonathan you're you have done an amazing
job in your in your columns laying all
of this out and there's a lot of factors
in play here the gun charge to me it
while important especially considering
Joe Biden's position on guns he lied on
a gun application that to me is just a
way to try and appease the public
because they've been exposed as trying
to give a sweetheart deal to Hunter but
when you have Joe Biden promising as a
candidate and a president over and over
again that he never had conversations
with his brother with hunter or anybody
about foreign business deals and then
Devin Archer testifies that in fact he
was privy to at least 20 calls where
joke called in then we know about the
Dubai call with barisma Executives just
what four or five days before Joe went
to Ukraine and leveraged a billion
dollars then you look at the sheer
amount of money that the Biden family is
getting funneled through show
corporations nine Biden family members
identified as being recipients
no experience at all that would warrant
this type of payment except their
connection to Joe and then the very
specific action of firing the prosecutor
to me I feel we're looking at a real
bribery money laundering Scandal these
are allegations and it seems that David
Weiss has no intention to look get into
it
well it doesn't take much of an effort
to reach the obvious conclusion you know
they're lying I mean the president lied
when he ran for office he said he didn't
know about these business dealings even
Hunter Biden's Close Associates said
that's patently Falls other Witnesses
have said they spoke to President Biden
about the business dealings uh these
issues were raised not only with the SEC
but the state department raised Hunter
Biden's dealing so it undermined the
efforts to deal with uh corruption in
the Ukraine so it's not particularly
complex
and that's part of what's so shocking
here is the effort by people in
government and by the media to not see
what's happening it's like you know you
used to have a Houdini would make an
entire elephant disappear from a stage
well the elephant never left the stage
but Houdini knew that the audience
really wanted it to disappear and that's
what has happened in Washington they
want the elephant to disappear and it
did and the bidens really take credit
for the magic trick of the century it
they made an obvious Scandal disappear
in front of an audience of Millions well
where does this go from here because
anybody with eyes to see can see exactly
what happened here and we're talking
about tens of millions of dollars
Jonathan we're talking about direct
actions taken as vice president and the
consequence the result of which is the
enrichment of the vice president's
family and it wasn't just one country it
was some of our top geopolitical foes
Jonathan that to me is a clear present
danger at a national security risk to
the country
well what's what's notable Sean is that
the best argument now for an impeachment
inquiry is being made by attorney
general Garland you know the we now know
that when many of us were objecting that
the statute of limitations was running
on some of these crimes those same
objections were being raised to Weiss in
the Department of Justice inside the
government and they apparently wanted
the statute of limitations to run on the
most serious of those tax crimes and now
you have a stonewalling of Congress on
many of these allegations of corruption
that leaves congress with very little
choice you know they can continue to
engage in this game of chicken with the
administration to see who's going to
jump out first or they can change the
game they can start an impeachment
inquiry because whatever Hunter Biden
did or did not do it's unlikely he's
going to be punished to the full extent
of the law but in the end that's not the
main problem the main problem is what
was done to protect him from the law and
what is still being done to do so
Jonathan this raises serious questions
with regard to his father is it well
that was my next question is it really
about Hunter at that point or is about
his father that was active and involved
in making all this happen and the family
benefiting because of it
it's it's about his father Sean I mean
the fact is you know the White House
actively involved including creating a
war room in anticipation of an
impeachment inquiry and they're actively
involved in pers in pushing this
narrative he has bootstrapped these
earlier actions into his administration
well all right we're going to continue
to follow this every every detail it's
important country is going to wake up to
this Jonathan Turley thank you hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else